between you and me you know that jello
is the best instrument right
[Music]
it is explosive
hello i'm yo-yo mom i'm here to answer
your questions on twitter
this is cello support
let's see what you got this is from at
stale bread
why do cellists play sweet number one
in every movie you mean
i think that movement represents the
infinitude of what we have
in the natural world so you think of
[Music]
flow
water
[Music]
sunlight sparkling on
leaves of trees on a fall day
we all can imagine something that is
both constant and always changing this
music actually helps in films to
actually
set a tone for what that movie is trying
to say
that music can help people get to a
certain state of mind
at ashley emrick do cellists have to
take a course on expressing emotions
through eyebrows
what does that magically happen when you
pick up the bow
how about do you have to take a course
on showing the motion when you're happy
to see your friend
i rest my case tough car 420
why are cellos so hard to tune cellos
are hard to tune
if you use the big pegs
but there are fine tuners that go much
more subtle
i hate to tune on stage when someone
goes
out on stage it goes
[Music]
they can tune off stage there's not that
much to adjust i play out of tune anyway
so if i tune and if it's in tune it
actually gives me even less of an excuse
at illuminous how the hell do cello
players
differentiate the frets guess what there
are no friends
i can play a sliding cello if i had
friends it would sound
for 60 years i've been moving between
this space and that space and i'm still
trying to get it right
because my fingers have to figure out
where
i need to be in order to get the right
sounds out at inikolu what
does vibrato mean so here's a note
without vibrato
[Music]
this is with vibrato you can hear the
vibrations
it's like a sine wave it can go as wide
as you want
the idea is you give warmth to the sound
by moving but hopefully not
always using the exact same amplitude
which is sort of like focusing
a light beam as a laser so that
when you go higher up you can use a
tighter beam and you go to lower
can use a wider amplitude and all these
variations
allow you to choose what kind of emotion
what kind of expression
you want sometimes that's an expressive
thing sometimes it's just a technical
thing
so it just gives you lots and lots of
things to play with
at wrapper why do cellos all move their
heads about
all over the place is it possible to
play it and just sit still like lots of
other musicians do
the idea of being a musician is that
you're there to transcend
technique in order to express the worst
thing you can do
is to play don't move your head and no
expression comes out
[Music]
that's the worst of all possible choices
but if you have to move
in order to actually pull the sound out
so to play
[Music]
takes a lot of energy in order to get
something out
hooray to people who don't need to but
just remember that's
great only if you are being maximally
expressive motion is about communicating
energy
too much motion you become less
efficient in actually
producing the sound that you're you're
you're doing but there's a physical
aspect
that needs to be considered in
conjunction with
how much expression you want to give at
287s why are cellos the most beautiful
instrument that is of course your
opinion
i try and tell cellists and especially
young cellists
between you and me so you know that
jello is the best instrument right
i love the cello it's an instrument that
has a lot of versatility i can play
bass lines i can play
melodic stuff i can
[Music]
i can play fast i can play slow i can
play melodically i can play bass lines i
can play rhythmic grooves
i can actually imitate vocal sounds
that's why i love it
because i can do a lot of different
types of music on it
and i can explore lots of different
musics
with it at the feet of god why are
cellos
so expensive a good maker can make
maybe one or two cellos a year
so how do you bend wood and shape it and
glue it under pressure
it's that kind of pressure
that actually allows air molecules
inside
the instrument to get excited so it
creates
more energy and that creates the big
sound
that an acoustic cello can make over
what an acoustic guitar can make where
the
table is flat so the curve
you bend carefully over heat you do it
so that it doesn't break
and it takes a long time and takes
strength it takes time
and obviously expertise the kind of wood
that
a lot of modern makers use are old wood
this is usually maple
and the flame goes this way and the
spruce goes this way
why because the maple is harder wood
the air molecules go to the back of
the wood the harder wood it bounces back
out
just the way that if you bounce a
basketball off of a backboard
it bounces back the harder the wood the
easier it will bounce
so expensive yes time takes a long time
if you may get it by a machine it's less
expensive
at dawn ship what are cello strings
made of these days the higher strings
are thinner they're made of steel
the lower strings it's steel wound
possibly on nylon strings used to be
made
with gut the gut is actually quite
strong makes a very warm sound gut as
as you might imagine it's made out of
you know animal material
it stretches so you have to constantly
tune
these gut trees and the steel actually
is
stronger and more stable so you tend to
if you
break in a new string it's easier to
break it in
than a gut string which may take a week
for it to actually maintain
its stable length the people who use
gut strings tend to be the um
the historic minded people who are
playing like historic
instruments and i think the best strings
are made in scandinavia or northern
europe
at eileen bejan can celeste
get cello elbow so i assume is this like
tennis elbow yes
people actually get tendonitis
tendonitis of
the elbow the hands fingers
part of what we do is very athletic
for all of you tell us that are in
danger of getting cello elbow i have
just
one piece of advice stretch and you can
stretch by
going like this which stretches your
muscles this way
go in a wall and you can see this
actually really hurts
and if you stand and you kind of rotate
on your foot if you go in a circle
you're stretching everything from here
to there when you're young
you're first of all immortal you think
you live forever
knowing yourself knowing your body
is maybe the first role of being a
musician
being in touch with how you feel
how you think how your body moves
head heart and hands make them work
together
and you'll be fine at levante carson
you could do a collaboration with a rap
artist
who would it be when i was working in
chicago a guy who did so
much for the community and for education
was common and i actually have a friend
who played in the civic orchestra
who was a violist and she worked with
kamen and
loved it so i would love to first of all
be able to thank him for what he's done
for the community and secondly i would
love to be able to do something with him
at sd monroe do string players attend
a plucking class i once asked my parents
both professional musicians that got a
flank stare
the reason it's harder to pluck on
instruments that have a curvature
versus on a guitar where you actually
have a flat
plane it's a little harder to pick
and actually pluck with the same
rapidity
that you can on a guitar there are
people
that do this unbelievably well i would
go to one of those people
berkeley school of music is a great
place where you can kind of
find people that will teach you you know
fiddling techniques and
plucking techniques it's kind of a sub
specialty
that is certainly worth pursuing and if
you can do it
hey that's a very cool thing at sydney
christie
uh is the cello hard to learn the cello
itself
is not hard to learn the most important
thing
is about pulling and pushing the bone
making sure that you find the right spot
on the strings
if it gives you pleasure if learning
gives you pleasure
and you can get pleasure from the
physical sound and from the vibrations
you're in you can progress if you say
it's really hard to learn
and it's difficult and you're all tight
and trying
to make it happen then it will be hard
so it really depends partly
on your attitude and then also on
how resilient you are to figuring out
what you need to do to create a sound
that is pleasing
that's it at wayne marx stumps
how to jealous play the six bach
cello suite without crying out for joy i
love that question because
it is explosive
and it just goes and goes and goes and
never ends and it gets
more explosive it gets more celebratory
and the skies open up
and you're right it is incredibly joyous
you cannot play that music without
actually
being in that same state of mind maybe
that's why we love music because
it actually puts you into different
states of mind that
makes me feel like i'm floating
somewhere up in the sky
from the clouds you're soaring above
the tree line you see vistas it takes
you places
music is a mode of transportation
that takes us from one reality into and
imagined
the reason i'm not crying out for joy is
because
i'm hopefully crying out for joy through
the sounds that are coming from the
children
[Music]
i just want to thank you all for your
questions very often there are no right
answers
but i think for me the best questions
are the questions
that make us ask even more questions
and that brings out i think the best of
what
is in us so thank you very much